نتقدم الان نحو الشريط الحدودي الفاصل بين
بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا التقارير الوارده من
هناك تتحدث عن توتر متصاعد وسط خروقات
استفزازيه وحشود لحرس الحدود
هذه هي الحدود البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه وقد
اصبحت تبدو بهذا الشكل كييف تنشئ جدارا
عازله من الخرسانه والاسلاك الشائكه على
طول الخط الفاصل في مناطق عداء بين الدول
تحتطاته من الخطر بقوته من جيشها تدعموا
حرس الحدود
مستشفى
الاسمنتيه في بعض المناطق الحدوديه ومن
خلفها خنادق مضاده لحركه الدبابات
بينما تجوز السماء مسيرات وان تم اسقاطه
لبعض منها
الطيار نحو مناطقنا الحدوديه ومنذ فتره
قصيره قمنا باسقاط مسيره كانت تقوم
بعمليات استطلاع فوقها
الجدار الفاصل الذي يمتد الان لبضعه
كيلومترات يعيدنا بالذاكره الى جدار برلين
الذي شاطر اوروبا الى قسمين وانتهى بالدم
لكن ما يزيد الطين بالله هو زرع الالغام
في الارض المشتركه بين البلدين ما ينذر
بموسم حصاد يتصيد الارواح والاطراف على
مدى 10 سنين عبد الجواد الروش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث من الحدود البيلاروسيه
الاوكرانيه